do it okay
I guess I smell ammonia they must have
done a thorough cleaning recently I like
that
I remember if anybody bothers you what
do you say my dad's a football coach and
my brother's a football player good hey
mom look that girl's pregnant
congratulations
all right everybody my name is Miz
McElroy in addition to being your
homeroom teacher I'll be seeing some of
you in my English class some of you on
the volleyball court just to give you a
little history I've been here at Medford
for 29 years I thought some of your
older brothers and sisters and sadly
some of your parents not much haven't
seen until today I'm sure you're well
aware we have a student with us who
despite his young age is remarkably
gifted and I expect y'all to make him
feel welcome yes shelton per the student
dress and grooming code this boy's hair
is too long this boy's wearing sports
attire outside of a designated area and
this girl's blouse is diaphanous which
means I can see her brassiere
thank you I will take that into account
all right we have a few minutes before
first period I need y'all to fill out
these forms
what also in violation of the grooming
code on page 48 article 5 subsection B
you have a bit of a mustache this boy
does not belong in our school come on
Vicki it's just the first day why don't
we all just take a deep breath here the
hell with that five minutes into my math
class he questioned my credentials am I
supposed to classroom when a kid accuses
me of being in breach of the hygiene
code well he wouldn't kill you to shower
a little more often George you wanna
wear you in here well Oral Roberts
University is a wonderful school he said
I was intimidated by his intelligence
and then he offered to be my leader
George you got any thoughts here I
certainly do Mary tell it's simple we
don't have a choice
well you gave it a shot we wish you luck
he's showing us where no no no we don't
have a choice he's got to stay here we
can't afford private school I sure can't
homeschool him he's doing calculus and
Euclidean something clearly in geometry
guess where I learned that yeah yeah we
know all I care about is that my son
gets the education he deserves so you
all are gonna have to figure this out
can you help me out here please
cuz I'm dying I'd rather not
[Music]
you